hello in this video I would describe and
try to solve questions with you from IT
Jam biological science and biotechnology
and the topic is immunology so every
year they ask one or two questions from
immunology in both biological signs or
particular paper so immunology could be
a very important strategy to get good
maths because the questions that they
ask are kind of elementary and if you
learn the basic concepts so you can
easily answer so this is one of the very
important topics I would say so let's
move on to the questions this question
was asked in our teacher and biological
science 2018 and the question says on
infection by a specific virus a host
cell generates cytotoxic T cell that
kill infected cell expressing self MHC
infected cell expressing MHC of
different genotype an infected cell
expressing self MHC cells infected by an
unrelated virus expressing self MHC and
the answer would be infected cell
expressing the self MHC now I will try
to explain the concept so cytotoxic T
cell provides immunity against viruses
here is a cell infected by the virus so
the virus would take control over the
host cell machinery for producing
proteins and it would produce viral
proteins which would be normally
degraded by the Bible by the cellular
mechanism known as proteasome mediated
proteases and some of those proteins
could be loaded horn class 1 MHC
molecules in the ER and displayed onto
the surface of the cells that could be
recognized the viral peptide bound class
1 MHC could be recognized by a cytotoxic
T cell sedative see T cell are full of
secretory granules consisting of
transient and buffering so they would
secrete grams I'm and perforin which
would ultimately trigger apoptotic
pathway the second example a second
question that they asked in 2018 in
biological science paper is an example
of trans cytosis is transmission of
north
Falls from cell-to-cell pancreatic cells
recruiting pancreatic juice and infant
getting antibodies from mothers milk a
micro fudge engulfing a bacteria and the
correct answer is an infant kitten
antibodies from mothers milk
so the trance cytosis process is kind of
similar to endocytosis and exocytosis a
combination of both in this process the
securing molecule traverses from
interest from one side and exits from
other side of the epithelial cell
so here the secretion molecule is IG a
type receptor IC a type antibody so IgE
antibody one secreted from the plasma
cell binds to the specific peptide of
the alkene receptor on the epithelial
cell gets a missile toast and get
exercisers from the other side so this
is called Tran statuses as you can see I
have taken this image from cookies in
middle of the sixth edition from chapter
the antigen antibody so they have
directly taken this concept from there
and asked it inform a format of a
question now also another question was
asked in biotechnology 2018 which says
that antibody binds to an antigen in
solution through several several
interaction like ionic bonds Vandellas
interaction and which one is true or
which ones are true so this is the
multiple option question so msq so
multiple option could be correct so and
the optional and the correct options are
all of them are correct and also in the
cookies immunology 6th edition you can
see but then described all sort of
interaction that is possible now
antibodies generally exhibiting known
who will end the interaction
all those interactions are given there
are all non-covalent and all are
possibly in the aqueous environment so
all these options would be correct so as
you can see I have this kind that they
are taking the concepts from the book
directly and asking it informative
question now another question was asked
in 2017 biotechnology probably so the
question says gene rearrangement in
which of the following cell types lead
to antigen receptor diversity in immune
cell and the options are macrophages
b-cell NK cell and T cell soapy film has
P cell receptor which is a membrane
bound antibody so PL
center generation definitely requires
vdj recombination and also the t cell
the TCR the T cell receptor also
requires specific alpha and beta gen
recombination to happen so which is very
similar to a villager recombination of
the form form a t-cell receptor so
basically T cell receptor and b-cell
receptor both need to go to recover a
rearrangement and recombination process
to generate antigen receptor diversity
so this is the correct option now
another question was asked in 2017 BL
probably now the cell involved in
allergic reaction and containing surface
receptor IgE antibodies and histamines
are a serval muscle mosaic and
neutrophils so the question simply
wanted to know that what are those cells
which have surface receptors of IgE that
means the FC receptors which can bind to
IG EF solution and also the secret
history and the correct option is
basically and muscle see that it's in
the chapter of cookies immunities
seventh edition in the allergy and
hypersensitivity reaction chapter so
where they have given that what cell
secretes what type of cytokine and
everything so mass still and basal feel
both has FC receptor and I have a
separate video on how this mass cell
basically functions in case of a allergy
response I would recommend to recommend
you to watch that now our question in 19
by technology 2016 where they asked a
pure rgg antibody was run on a SDS page
under reducing condition how many bands
would you see after staining with a coma
simply an answer is two the reason being
so you can see here is an antibody and
there are ties alpha disulfide linkages
in blue and in a reducing condition when
you're giving SDS page these disulfide
bonds would be gone so basically you
would get kind of four chains two heavy
chains two light chains now see
like heavy chains two of the heavy teams
are of same molecular weight so they
would appear as one band and two light
chains since they are all kind of
similar molecular weight they would have
here as another band so you would
ultimately get two bands in a massive
you stay another question was asked in
2016 BL or PT maybe 2016 BT
where it asked that identified the
autoimmune disease among the following
and options are type 2 diabetes type 1
diabetes and gestational diabetes and
parnesius
anemia and the first option is type 1
diabetes mellitus again this question
was taken from another table in chapter
the dialer gene hypersensitivity chapter
so you can see there is a list given off
there is a list of diseases given where
type 1 diabetes mellitus is actually
autoimmune diseases where the th cell
actually activates plasma cell to
produce antibodies against the
pancreatic beta cells and creates severe
inflammatory response and all these
things so this is a came taken from
coupies immunology so they are over and
over every year kind of taking concepts
from coupies immunology and asking
questions directly from the book another
question was asked where it says antigen
binding site of an antibody molecule
consists of and in terminal domain of
heavy chain and c-terminal domain of
light chain in terminal domain of heavy
chain and in terminal domain of light
chain so anything like that so the
correct option would be this because you
can see if here is an antibody and they
are here would be the n-terminal region
of the heavy chain in terminal region of
the light chain so the antibody binding
groove is present here the hyper
variable loops if you remember if you
wanted details about this you can watch
my videos about antibody structure and
function so I hope you enjoyed this
video and this video was informative so
I would give all the relevant concepts
accord with these videos in the
descriptions and if you want to learn
about community I have an immunology
playlist where you can which you can
refer so I hope you enjoyed please like
share and subscribe thank you